well we can turn to labor now and talk
to the shadow business secretary uh
jonathan reynolds um i'm sure you were
listening to that interview uh therese
coffey said
that the prime minister was not aware of
specific
claims about the behavior of chris
pincher when he was made deputy chief
whip in february
what did you make of that
well i i thought parts of that were
desperate to be honest i think we've got
to acknowledge what the consistent
problem is and it is a conservative
party that repeatedly chooses to do what
is politically expedient over what is
right and that's whether that's the
matter of those mps that were charged
with serious sexual offences at charlie
elfic and andrew griffiths who would
then let back into the conservative
party because that was the short-term
interest they adopted um it's clear from
what we know uh this morning that chris
benson should never have been put back
into the whips office it's a wider
pattern of behavior too isn't it owen
patterson breaking the rules and then
having the secret the conservative party
seeking to redraw those rules to his
advantage and if you have a situation no
matter what else is going on where
people believe no matter what they do
they will not be held accountable to
that because of their relationship to
boris johnson or the position or the
internal politics of the conservative
party i think you are asking for the
kind of problems which they have got and
i'm so frustrated that again the whole
reputation of politics and parliament in
this country is being besmirched by this
i accept uh that the more recent cases
have been skewed towards the
conservative party i do accept that but
there have been issues within the labour
party as well have i not um the majority
mp's conservative but mike hill ivan
lewis calvin hopkins all labour mps who
have resigned in the last few years
over their conduct the investigation to
kevin hopkins didn't even reach
conclusion because it took so long that
he resigned his membership and the
complainant in that case labour activist
tweeted to say that she hopes kirsten
listens to her concerns and fixes this
broken system
labour is also not squeaky clean on this
are you no well a case like that is not
acceptable and i can tell you it
wouldn't happen again as well as being
the shadow business secretary i'm a
member of the labour party's national
executive committee i have the
humilities of it to know yes we have
problems i'm often a person who has to
respond and deal with those but i can
tell you that we don't have what i
observe in the conservative party which
is the repeated
decision to make the wrong decision if
that's in whatever short-term interest
they perceive they have i don't think
they've taken these things seriously i
think they've made decisions which they
shouldn't have made
i can't believe some of the things that
are in the papers today about what the
prime minister may have personally been
aware of before he made decisions like
this and but all the politics suffers
that there's no doubt about that it it
affects the reputation of us all that's
what i find so frustrating and i think
it's right that people demand better
you know it feels kind of slightly
depressing that you know i do these
interviews about these stories on a
regular relatively regular basis and i
often ask people what should actually
change in parliament and it feels as if
people just don't come up with any
answers teresa's coffee
was defending the use of bars defending
the use of mps directly employing their
staff i just wonder what your position
is on that 30 bars in the parliamentary
estate six in the house of commons the
house of lords is it now time to shut
the bars
look i don't think sophie parliament has
the kind of modern workplace culture
that it should have i think there's
further to go on that but i would just
say if you look at these particular
incidents actually few of them are in
parliament itself so for me it comes
down to something bigger than the
hospitality arrangements it's about
power it's about accountability it's
about the the standards that are set by
the leader by the leader of each
political party and i cannot see boris
johnson as being the kind of person to
somehow improve the culture of the
conservative party he himself you know
we don't even need to go through the
things that he has been saying just to
go back to the quest just to go back to
the question you don't think there's a
need to shut parliament's bars then well
i think there is only one major bar for
members of parliament there's a one for
for staff as well i'm not sure the other
ones are probably the restaurants but no
i don't think that is the issue i think
the problem is not you you could shut
every bar in westminster but if you've
got a conservative party that does not
take these issues seriously that gives
people that get out of jail foreign
but genuinely you know i do think most
people listening to this just won't
understand like lots of people work long
hours lots of people work late very very
few people work in workplaces where
there is a drinking culture that is
effectively encouraged because you have
bars in parliament
well i i wouldn't say it's encouraged
most people are doing an incredibly
professional job and where there are for
instance there's a bar for staff members
i think that is to be honest absolutely
fine and what i'm trying to say to you
is this is not the core of the issue you
know i think particularly that the chris
pinchkes i understand was that the
conservative party's private members
club the carlton club so there are other
issues than the bars and that cannot be
the side issue we've got to address the
core of this which is poor behavior
that's been set from the top what about
um what about the idea put forward by
the speaker that mp should no longer
directly employ their own staff which
would obviously make hr complaints
easier if it's your direct line manager
that is you know the issue
i have no complaints personally about
that i think as long as mps are able to
select their interview and select the
right staff members for them i would
also say the most important thing this
is it just just just to come in if you
don't mind um because you you're
obviously uh upset by the story i get it
you know you you've come on and very
strongly explained why you find it
troubling but what do you think should
change i understand that you're going to
give me an answer about the conservative
party but surely we should be looking at
things that can practically change in
parliament to try and stop this kind of
behavior or at least make a bit of a
difference but for me it comes down to
are mps going to be held accountable for
their actions are they going to have the
right standard of leadership set from
the topic is there going to be you know
some of the people were talking those
are good words but there's no actual
change there is there
wouldn't be change if people took this
seriously and therefore made decisions
accordingly if you have a situation
where someone has resigned for a certain
set of behaviors and you then appoint
them not just to the whips office but to
be in charge of the welfare of other mps
well of course that's the wrong decision
that's what needs to change and that
just clearly hasn't been a factor in the
prime minister's considerations here at
all okay um
there's just to move on to some other uh
issues now there's chaos at the airports
at the minute anyone trying to book a
holiday will be very well aware of it
the government's come forward with some
plans today where they want to
fast-track track security checks for
baggage handlers to try and ease the
staffing issues does labor support that
or are you worried about any security
risk well i want to see the department
of transport get a grip on this travel
chaos i saw that story last night to be
frank i think they've probably just come
up with that to try and get through the
media round today there seems to me to
have been no planning at the stage of
the pandemic that required it to look at
what would happen when we came out of
the pandemic in terms of the job losses
that had taken place
at airports in particular about the
complex relationship between the home
office employees the airline staff and
the airport staff to make sure we had
the capacity to do it so it feels like
they're playing a little bit of catch up
today but they do need to get a grip of
it uh okay um and then just finally uh
tony blair said this week on a podcast
that he supports what kirsten was doing
but he then went on to say the central
problem is what are the ideas that are
going to stop this relegation and put
the uk on an upward path there's been a
gaping great hole where ideas should be
do you agree that there's been a gaping
great hole where idea should be
no i think this has been a gap in great
hall but i think tony blair's analysis
of what this country needs in terms of
having a plan to turn around the last
decade of poor growth poor productivity
downward pressure on wages is absolutely
essential i was doing a big speech this
week at the um society of motor
manufacturers summit about how the state
could be a partner to make sure we've
got the battery factories that we need
in order to make sure we continue to
make electric vehicles in this country
aren't and don't lose out to competitors
and that is what is required if you look
at the conservative party this
government what are they offering you
bring back imperial measurements a trade
war with the european union that is not
the way forward if you look at what
we're saying and of course we've got to
develop this it's that exciting
long-term vision for industrial policy
in this country to make sure there are
good jobs and of course that we hit our
climate change commitments so i think
he's right to say that's what this
country needs but i think labour is the
party offering that and the government
frankly have just run out of ideas
okay uh thank you very much for being on
the program today jonathan reynolds